[Music]
it's never been easier we're never gonna
live longer and so just shifting the
mindset that where you start has to be
where you end up I just say fast-forward
to the end of your life and look back
and just make that make that pain so big
that it forces you to do something now I
think the pain right now is real
switching is real switching sucks the
the feeling like you wasted years on
something the emotional toll that it
takes on you you having to explain it to
other people that you're moving on to
something else that pain is real and
sucks but it's nothing compared to the
pain that you'll have of staying in it
the problem is the immediate pain feels
bigger the immediate pain of having to
tell your parents and your friends that
you're moving on to something else feels
big and the day-to-day of staying in
your job doesn't feel as big and a
one-day timeline it's worse to quit and
tell your friends and move on to
something else it feels worse the pain
is bigger but if you accumulate all of
those little losses all of those micro
pains every day of staying into that job
it ends up being way way way way way
bigger and so just trying to force that
so be that future pain becomes so big in
the present that it makes you break the
right decision
[Music]
you don't need to go full-time like a
war you don't need to quit your job and
go full-time and be broke for the next
three years of your life you don't need
to go off and do that you can find a way
to start you're gonna tell me that in
this crappy job that you hate and in
what you're doing and your regular life
going home that you're being you're
using your time 100% effectively like
let me sit with you for a day and audit
how you're spending your time we can't
find an hour a day to work on your
business or your next thing or the
training you need to get to the next
level right you want to be a
photographer but you don't know anything
about photography we go take a class if
you can't find a night a week they will
take a class and play with it on your
own right just people you don't need to
quit you don't need to take a flame
thrower to your boss's office you don't
need to leave immediately you can start
on the side you can find a way do you
need to spend all the money that you're
spending right now if you left your job
and took on something where you you're
getting paid three-quarters as much but
you're happy as anything maybe that's a
good trade like is it worth staying in a
crappy job just so you can drive that
car or would you I should be happy and
drive it around like maybe that's a good
trade but if it's not then you start on
the side and you slowly build it up
people want to do all or nothing and it
doesn't have to be that black and white
you just build a plan to move towards it
I think that's where a lot of people
fall down like you do not need to quit
your job
[Music]
I think the other part is still the
financial part is an excuse I think if
you really sat down and found a little
way just shifting the mindset from how
am I gonna be able to pay these bills to
how am I gonna be able to pay those
bills just in the mindset that this is
achievable I'm gonna set my mind to
solving it instead of just despair and
giving up if you shift your mindset you
will find answers and I think still a
lot of people are so having their
identity wrapped up with the thing that
they do I am A
when somebody asks you what you do for a
living I think you should stumble I
think if you can clearly answer like oh
I'm a I'm a videography do AG refer
doesn't should not explain what you do I
think you should have a hard time
explaining what you do
I think people identify too much with
the work that they do and then switching
it isn't just about money and resources
it's about shift into identity but now I
want to be this person I'm starting over
and they don't have the humbleness to
start from the beginning again where
they've gotten some success and they've
gotten four promotions and they like
good is the enemy of great if you suck
at your job and you've been there for
twenty years and you've never got a
promotion and you're still doing minimum
wage it's easy to leave that job to go
do something out but if you're getting
some results you're getting you just got
promoted and you just got your manager
now you've got your first employee
working under you you're getting some
accolades and some rewards and
recognition it's hard to jump off the
back to then go off and be something
else because you've identified yourself
with that role and the further you go
down that path the hardest going to be
to jump off
[Music]
expected to take longer than you think
it's gonna take when don't expect
immediate results this is what I had the
hardest time late I thought I thought it
was going to take a long time but ended
up still taking way longer and I was too
afraid to tell my friends and too
ashamed and as a result I find really
internalize it and felt like a worthless
human being so just having those
expectations starts making sure that you
are making progress every day in some
small way helps I think when momentum
stops that's when your world starts to
blow up and so what is it that you need
to do on a daily basis to build some
momentum in and I think having the
starting point I think you got a chart
your start
what's the beginning what is your
morning look like so what is the thing
that gets you feeling bold and
courageous and passionate and excited
we've all felt it what is the thing for
you that gets you feeling that and then
do that in the morning it's hard when
you're by yourself it's hard when you
don't have an office to go to it's hard
when the people around you think you're
crazy it's hard when you're not seeing
results right this is why it's so
important that you do something that
you're passionate about this is why I
like the number one piece of advice some
people who've accomplished in anything
it's like you got to love the thing
because it's so hard to keep going that
you're gonna quit like a normal sane
smart human being would quit but you
keep going because the big decisions you
have to make with your heart and not
your head and so doing the thing that
gets you feeling motivated and excited
as part of what I try to do like why do
I make my youtube channel is that
there's content every day there's no
excuse is a there's a piece of content
every day to help you believe in
yourself a little bit more and so if
watching my channel does it amazing if
you hate my channel awesome like just do
the thing that you need to do whether
it's playing music whether it's yoga
whether it's watching a video whether
it's meeting people for some people just
just having a human contact like go to a
coffee work from a coffee shop in the
morning just to be just to get out of
the house as a routine so it starts with
just thinking about what is the thing
that drives you that gets you motivated
that gets you feeling like like the work
you do matters
and then go do that cuz when you're in a
company you have a boss you're
responsible to you don't show up to work
your boss is gonna slime into you if
you're not doing great work your boss is
gonna be all over you if you don't get
your job done on time your boss is gonna
be upset your customers do that to some
extent you know you need to give a
deadline you need to get something done
but apart from that you are your own
boss and it's funny how much we will do
how far we'll push ourselves to appease
a boss that we hate but we won't push
ourselves for ourselves it's crazy and
so it's a mind game the individual
pieces of work that you have to do don't
matter it's the mind game it's like
getting your mind set straight every
morning not waking up like an accident
charting your start creating the routine
to set you up but that it takes you five
minutes or it takes you an hour whatever
you need to do you do that thing every
morning and you're feeling like you're
ready to go off and build the thing that
you want to build otherwise you're just
constantly riding that roller coaster of
motivation and you're most likely
staying at the bottom instead of being
at the top I think people are so afraid
to to risk making a change I think
people get on one path and and then they
end up stuck on that path forever and I
think that's why most people hate their
jobs and hate their life like they knew
thirty years ago that this was not the
thing for them it has to be something
that you feel passionate about it's easy
to stay on the same path and be
frustrated and be grow more and more
angry and I think the excuses will only
pile up as you get older once you have
kids once you have a husband or wife
it's only gonna be more typical to jump
off that path I think one of the biggest
reasons why people don't end up jumping
off is because they're surrounded by a
bunch of safe players a bunch will hate
their life and that's that's normal
your friends your parents your family
everybody is doing the thing that they
hate and they've accepted it and so you
accept it and so if you change your
environment sex around yourself with
people who are doing big things we're
doing both things took the chance of
themselves we're willing to make that
shift then you start to believe it a
little bit more yourself for me my
passions entrepreneurs because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur the
the lack of self-worth the suffering the
feeling of judgment all of that that
happened to me in my first business
sucked and it's the best because now
it's fueled all of the stuff that I've
now created it's now become my mission
and I still have many many more decades
ahead of getting content all because of
that really short brief painful moment
growing up
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people with passion can change the world
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
Rose a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual Clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details